designing each creature is a
collaborative effort between the
character concept of animation
departments we start by trying to
visualize the anatomy of the creature
and ask ourselves if this is something
that could actually exist I mean there
are fantastical creatures but we don't
want them to defy the laws of physics in
order to become the best monster hunter
you must first learn how to understand
your foes books and essays usually gives
you the information you need where they
can be found their attack pattern and
what they fear and it is your job to
figure out the best way to kill them
Garrett has a lot of tools available at
his disposal for fighting enemies in The
Witcher 3 is steel sword for instance is
used primarily for fighting the human
opponents and his silver sword which he
uses for fighting monsters Daryl can
also use a crossbow for fighting ranged
or flying foes that are trying to keep
their distance from him crossbow is also
very useful for fighting underwater
against swimming monsters such as the
siren harpies are vile feather creatures
that fly around you and circle you now
the only way to deal with them it's
first to bring them down and that's
where your art spell comes in handy sort
of compressed air there will bring them
down to the ground where you can finish
them with your sword some monsters in
The Witcher 3 can actually swim these
can attack the player while he's in the
water and even go as far as attacking
his boat this could be really dangerous
for the player if the monster has a
natural affinity for water such as the
drowner drowners are creatures they'll
live in swamps and will snatcher
anything that comes near their ponds and
these particular creatures absolutely
hate fire and they fear it and that's
where your Ignace spell flame that
bursts out of your hand
comes in handy and that is the best way
to kill them
with the werewolf a bomb filled with
silver powder will take away his
regenerative abilities this will make it
much easier for the players to defeat
him after the player can use weapon oils
to coat his weapons that will make them
do enhanced damage against specific
enemy types the real trick to use in
this though is to know when and where to
use them and that judgment is left up to
the players based on his surrounding
environment the weather and even
territorial marks that other monsters
may arrest in the area so we've created
this complex behavior system in the game
that actually allows these creatures to
live in the world that they inhabit
they're never just gonna spawn in front
of you artificially and they don't just
interact with the player their act with
each other and with NPCs we've created a
unique ecosystem that includes monsters
animals and humans all living together
fighting trying to survive and you are
merely a spectator now it is your choice
to interfere with whatever is happening
in front of you but don't forget every
action you take in the wood shop has its
own consequences